[Music]  with Fisk behind bars what's next  the city's safer than ever maybe Peter  Parker can have more life are you in  trouble do you need me no no I mean I'm  a little behind on my rent but no I'm  I'm fine take care of this please it  represents the best part of me smiles  it's gonna be helping out around here  for acts of extraordinary bravery I'm  the one who kept order in their City  what is this Devil's breath your city  and everything you care about will be  destroyed people will beg you for help  but you won't be able to save them  get more backup  wait  we've got a play this just right  please stop maybe the city needs our  friend more than you think  who anyone else need a breather  [Music]  please